with women in the past my relationships
have been like love me love me and I'm
like no and then now when I'm dating men
I'm like love me love me and they're
like oh yeah
never oh I see straight guys I'd like to
do all the time yes 1,000% like a lot
it's my curse I fall in love with
straight men every day yeah yeah but not
necessarily because they're straight
it's more if they're hot I've never like
he's straight it's taboo that makes him
hotter - yeah it's just like I'm
attracted to all men if like a straight
guy is hot even if they were gay they'd
still be hot over time I've figured out
that if somebody is straight it's
actually a turn-off for me I kind of
lose a sexual desire for somebody if our
sexualities aren't compatible it's
really you've been a straight guy friend
or you're like yeah hit that yeah I
guess oh you poisoned me over here I
guess okay yeah I'm just trying to get
the truth out of you I guess I look at
straight men the same way I look at
women I can appreciate your beauty but I
don't really want to do anything
hell yes I've been attracted to women as
I've gotten older I've realized that I'm
attracted to like a manly man and like a
cute feminine woman I like a curvy lady
even now I look at women I'm like yeah I
think I could get on board as a kid I
was like I'm the gayest thing on earth
and now as an adult I'm like I'm hanging
out with my girlfriends alone and it's
making me feel like I want to kiss you
right now and I'm very confused nope
Jennifer Lopez you do JLo yeah it's
actually attractive okay I thought
Britney Spears was hot I've never wanted
to have sex with a woman Britney Spears
you had a whole wall of like photos of
her and then I started to grow up and I
uh ii think it's just it i want to be
them not that i want them definitely
always appreciated women's beauty I've
never been sexually attracted I think
girls are attractive I'll definitely be
like oh damaged
or just I never look at them sexually in
like damn yeah like you ever want to go
to their yeah
eighth grade for a week I did like her
but that she told me she was only dating
me because she wanted my best friend and
so yeah I have dated a woman before had
a fake 2-week relationship with a girl
in eighth grade
and it was bad I went on a couple dates
with a girl my freshman year of college
it seemed like the thing to do now I
don't watch a porn no yeah yes as a joke
on accident when it pops up as a pop up
on my gate board occasionally I will
indulge in a straight porn or a
threesome yeah yeah yeah I've been there
10% of my porn watching might be
straight might why sometimes the guy is
really hot I mean it may be watched a
couple for a specific guy to see what
he's up to
I can appreciate the storyline it's a
really funny comment thread on I think
it was ready what's the one thing you
would take out of porn and all the guys
said the shot of like the dudes like
butthole in straight porn I guess
they're doggy style the camera goes like
behind the guy and shoots him from
behind but all you see is like a
butthole in balls and I guess like the
straight men have read it we're not
impressed and didn't want that
I've never had sex with a woman and I
don't think I want to I've never had sex
with women I'm a gold star gay gold star
gay 100% gold star gay will it happen
though I don't know maybe yes I've had
sex with a woman it feels good and also
sex with men feels good to know the
closest I wrote was her vagina was when
I was born no no you can't like wake up
one day and be like my gay past is dead
you can maybe find a girl that like you
have attraction too and for some reason
it just works and you were so convinced
that you were just into guys but to turn
fully like all of a sudden like I woke
up tomorrow and I just want girls now
know your sexuality can change naturally
you can't force a change in sexuality
that doesn't work I don't think that
conversions of any type are legit or
healthy or right if they happen to
explore other types of sex I think that
that's perfectly fine as long as it is
in sync with what they're feeling yeah I
would have to agree because I would say
when I first came out I was like I'm gay
I like men that's it in the 15 years
that I've been out my sexual preferences
have like changed and I've actually have
found myself like attracted to women
more so than when I think I first came
out I don't think someone can make you
turn straight and it has to flow with
taste one day you might be into like
carne asada burritos and then you might
want a burger I don't know I don't know
these food analogies oh yes I have
flashback to the other line I lost my
virginity to do a straight guy all right
I've never hooked up with a straight
dude no I I'm not one of guys if you'd
be like oh hey straight boys boys sure
but yes me right now I'm like oh yeah I
have no game quite a few times of guys
like tell me like in secrecy that they
like me or had some quarter attraction
to me but like I don't know man like
I've never felt like about a guy this
way and like I don't know which confused
me man but I was like alright but I
didn't do anything with them a couple
times I did but sometimes something
not had full-on penetrative sex with a
straight man but I've definitely
explored with them other ways it
happened once tell me all about it it
was fun was he just like let's [ __ ] but
I'm not into guys I think he wanted to
experiment to see what it was like and I
was like okay I did it it was nice I
think at the end of it he was like oh I
don't know like I tried it I had a
curious fellow once and he halfway
through decided nope this was not for me
it was a lot of responsibility but right
am i giving him the full gay experience
right I think it's important for
everyone just to explore what you like
sexually hmm I think that's what your
early 20s are for is just like to try
different things or like your late 30s
yeah whenever you want to try something
I say try it and that's the only way to
know what you actually like and that's
how they're cookie crumbles the guys
always say like gay guys give better
heads because you don't have to ask for
it gets gay guys sometimes you just like
pull it I don't like
[Music]